the aurabora cycle one of the biggest
most legendary series of entries in the
history of the scp foundation we've
covered the events of this scp-001 epic
in six videos which we definitely
recommend you watch before this one to
avoid your brain exploding from the
sheer scope of it all because that's the
thing about the orborus cycle it's a
story so big sprawling and dense that it
can feel almost like an anomaly itself
whether you're immersed in the possible
origin of the broken god the sentient
black hole that can destroy the whole
universe or kelvin lucian's quest to
assassinate the o5 council it can
sometimes be difficult to see the forest
from the trees but worry not because
that's exactly why we're here today
we're going to step back and look at
this anomalous odyssey as a whole and
ask the big question why is it all here
together what makes these four different
storylines the children the broken god
atonement and the way it ends one big
cycle as with anything involving the scp
foundation there's always going to be an
element of personal interpretation but
now that we've gone through the whole
cycle we think it's worth adding our two
cents to the proceedings so let's start
broad a question you've probably been
wondering is what do the words orborus
cycle actually mean and what is their
significance to the four stories within
while the spelling can differ orboros
refers to the ancient symbol of a snake
or dragon eating its own tail forming a
circle a direct connection to the
concept of cycles the arbor symbol has
existed in a huge number of cultures
from the ancient egyptians to the
ancient greeks to modern gnostic
traditions it's often used in alchemy or
other magical practices and has a
variety of meanings such as eternal life
the endless cycle of death and rebirth
and the cycle of renewal anyone familiar
with the tales within the orbora cycle
is probably already noticing some
similarities cycles are a common theme
in all of these works people endlessly
repeat mistakes threats thought to be
contained or destroyed return and
oftentimes those who go out on a quest
to destroy something end up becoming
what they wish to destroy in the first
place in a cycle there is no true end
and no true beginning everything repeats
endlessly but let's start at the closest
thing to the beginning we have the
children in this tale the foundation
faces off against a terrifying reality
warping group of interests known as the
kingdom of abaddon this nasty group
which came from the sahara desert could
seemingly take anything the foundation
threw at them and were able to straight
up vaporize anyone who got too close if
the kingdom was able to amass enough
power it could spell the end of the
foundation and even the subjugation of
the human race enter 05-1 a reoccurring
character in the arboros cycle this
outside the box thinker put all his
chips on the twins of god project
designated
scp-001 like many anomalies before and
after it this project would infuse a
human being with godlike powers but it
was a power so great that it seemed to
kill anyone who attempted to accept it
needless to say this was a major bummer
for o5-1 but through relentless human
experimentation even sacrificing the
population of entire towns to the
project he eventually came up with a
solution a horrifying solution but a
solution nonetheless he found that a
group of nine children with ages varying
from four to 11 could act as a human
conduit for 001's power and as a result
it could be a weapon capable of turning
the tide against the kingdom of abaddon
during the testing phase though it
seemed like 05-1 went a little mad with
power he vaporized an entire church of
the broken god place of worship and used
the power of the children to wipe a few
others off the map at his own discretion
his abuses of power got so flagrant that
the administrator himself was called in
to get a handle on the situation and
surprise surprise 0-5-1 disintegrated
him too before disappearing himself
shortly afterwards in the end the
children were deemed too dangerous to be
practical both because of their
anomalous powers and from the level of
ambient radiation they put out all nine
were locked in radiation-proof boxes and
buried in the desert though they each
show signs of life to this day while
this may seem disconnected from the rest
of the series it actually establishes
some of the most important recurring
themes and ideas of the cycle as a whole
namely the foundation messing with
reality and performing horrific acts to
achieve their goals the corruption of
the o5 council and the fact that these
grand attempts to change or save the
world often blow up in everyone's faces
sometimes literally we also have the
introduction and apparent death of the
mysterious administrator but trust us
all is not what it seems with this one
the ripple effect beginning here will
affect everything going forward next the
broken god this tells the chaotic story
of a magical clockwork box which is
worshiped by the church of the broken
god as a conduit to their deity and
eventually becomes an all-devouring
mechanical kaiju the beast soon dubbed
scp-001 devoured and consumed all the
metal around it slowly becoming larger
and more destructive if the foundation
didn't take it out before it reached
critical mass they'd be going toe-to-toe
with a bonafide god a fight they really
weren't sure they could win thankfully
and with a little anomalous help from
scp-2399
the foundation was able to destroy the
anomaly they removed its clockwork card
from the wreckage and contained the
anomalous scrap that once comprised its
destructive body however the foundation
soon realized that you just can't keep a
good god down the clockwork heart
eventually evaded foundation containment
while being shipped to a secondary
location and instead ended up in a small
town here it began to influence the
minds of the residents into more
subservient broken god cultists intent
on building him back up to his former
glory it'd be easy to discount the
broken god as an outlier seeing as the
foundation came out looking much better
here than they do in any of the other
orboros tales but when you look
carefully its place in the overall cycle
is clear the entry ends the way it
begins with the heart of the broken god
influencing humans to carry out its
bidding the foundation had to intervene
in between these two instances but in
the end there was no net loss to the
broken god itself in a sense the
foundation is doomed to encounter the
same problems again and again
continually defending the world from the
same anomalous threats and the
foundation needs to succeed every time
to maintain peace and normality a major
anomalous threat only needs to succeed
once to drag everything into disarray in
many ways that is the curse of the scp
foundation speaking of major anomalous
threats now it's time for part three of
the orboro cycle atonement once again we
start off with the foundation meddling
with cosmic scale powers with the
creation of the area 11 pietro cal
fontaine spatial stabilization array try
saying that three times fast that was a
machine so powerful it was capable of
creating a singularity though what it
actually ended up doing was turning dr
calvin desmond into an abomination more
specifically into a kind of immensely
powerful humanoid black hole whose
powers were only restrained by the very
machine that created him think of him as
kind of a malicious dr manhattan from
watchmen this new entity dubbed scp-001
presented a grim prophecy and an ominous
offer he told the r5 council that
anomalies were leaking into their
universe from other realities and soon
the anomalous threat would destroy them
all his offer was to upon his release
wipe out the rest of the multiverse
entirely leaving only our reality free
from anomalous threats
unsurprisingly it was 05-1 that was most
interested in this offer so much so that
he held a vote and murdered everyone who
voted against the decision to release
scp-001 having built his consensus among
the survivors on the council 05-1 let
scp-001 out unsurprisingly this turned
out to be a terrible decision as one of
his first acts upon being freed was to
kill the members of the o5 council that
had just voted to release 001 saying
that they themselves were anomalous and
needed to be purged to atone for their
past sins the only survivor was a member
of the council who abstained from the
vote who was able to recontain scp-008
inside the petrocal fontaine array for
now once again the thematic connections
to the rest of the orboro cycle is clear
we have a world-ending anomaly held off
but only temporarily buying time before
the cycle inevitably continues we have
the foundation abusing its power and
signing off on the death of countless
people in other dimensions and of course
the o5 council stepped out of their
bounds and actively warped reality just
like they had with the children before
their chickens truly come home to roost
though in the final part of the cycle
appropriately named the way it ends this
piece chronicles the story of calvin
lucian and the kill squad an elite group
of four chaos insurgency soldiers with
one goal assassinating the entire o5
council 13 of the most powerful people
in the world why because they've been
messing with reality itself time and
time again and it's getting to the point
that their selfish meddling could
finally destroy everything and given
that we've already seen it happen with
the children and the entity that dr
calvin desmond became it's hard to
disagree with them what follows is one
of the longest and most complicated
tales in all of the foundation as the
kill squad systematically encounters and
kills each insane anomalous member of
the o5 council in order to do this they
need to make deals with death itself
fight giant serpents cross dimensions
deal with scp-610 and scp-682
containment breaches and go toe-to-toe
with samsara arguably the foundation's
deadliest mobile task force a number of
other insane things happen along the way
like 05-1 murdering the gate guardian
with the scranton reality anchor and the
black queen the most prominent member of
the serpent's hand helping our heroes
defeat more over sears in the end calvin
lucian despite losing almost everything
reigns victorious in the final battle
using the spear of the non-believer a
weapon so powerful it can kill gods
calvin managed to finally kill the top
member of the overseers
05-1 with the o5 council destroyed
calvin set about completing his final
task destroying the entire scp
foundation but that didn't happen
instead he was contacted by a mysterious
and immensely powerful being known as
the administrator who gave him some
frightening news he'd just been hired by
the scp foundation to be their new
05-1 this was where our last video on
the arborist series left us what happens
next you may ask how does calvin respond
to this offer he seemingly can't refuse
in this case it seems that the
administrator of being so completely
tied to the nature of the foundation
itself is
scp-001 and while it seemed that the
overseers were mad with power they were
actually always there to keep the
administrator in check aaron siegler the
05-1 that calvin had just killed was
doing the exact same thing calvin was
doing when he became 05-1
trying to destroy the foundation but the
foundation and the administrator cannot
be beaten they can only be joined and
that's exactly what calvin did becoming
the new 05-1 turning his back on the
chaos insurgency and rebuilding the rest
of the council and the foundation in his
own image insurgency members who were
once his allies vowed revenge for this
betrayal perhaps suggesting that history
would go on to repeat itself once more
in the future
because at the end of the day that's
what the oboro cycle really is the
recurring threat and the changing of the
guards that accompanies it there will
always be a foundation there will always
be an administrator there will always be
an 05 council nothing starts nothing
ends all that ever changes are the names
and faces involved whether it's calvin
lucian or aaron siegler the wheel keeps
turning the snake devours its own tail
the obora cycle is and forever will be
eternal now go check out our full piece
by piece breakdown on the orboro cycle
starting with scp-001 the children and
then check out
scp-5000y the full story compilation
just in case we haven't blown your mind
enough for one day